[Music]
U.S troops in South Korea Herald the
launch of a space arm at ozone Air Force
Base South of Seoul following a similar
ceremony in Hawaii three weeks earlier
it will be America's eyes in the sky
tracking missile activity in North Korea
in near real time to detect disrupt and
destroy you military is faster better
connected more informed precise and
lethal because of space among the nearly
70 ballistic missiles North Korea has
test fired this year is the so-called
monster missile the Hua song 17. it puts
the entire United States Within Reach
and could have the capability of sending
multiple nuclear warheads to multiple
destinations as North Korea ramps up its
military Ambitions be it developing
intercontinental ballistic missiles
submarine launch ballistic missiles or
indeed nuclear testing Washington Seoul
and Tokyo are strengthening their
military cooperation but experts in
Seoul say that the vision of U.S space
forces Korea is wider it aims to reach
across the greater indo-pacific region
and that means monitoring and acquiring
Intelligence on China at the Shangri-La
dialogue in Singapore earlier this year
defense secretary Lloyd Austin described
the Asia Pacific as a priority theater
for wash Washington calling for a
rules-based international order North
Korea analyst Kim Dong yup says
increasingly polarizing Global
geopolitics exacerbated by Russia's war
in Ukraine is leaving middle powers like
South Korea to choose a side if you
consider a missile flying from China to
the U.S Mainland you have Hawaii in the
middle and South Korea is the closest
point to China even more so than Japan
the details of U.S space forces Korea
such as its size are not yet known nor
how it will work with seoul's newly
launched space operations Squadron under
its Air Force Eunice Kim Al Jazeera
Seoul